welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and with King the Conqueror on Deck
as the big bad of Marvel Phase 5 and
phase six a man who in quantumania
footage displays a terrifying amount of
amnesia for the amount of Avengers he
has killed new visual Clues from Loki
revealed in a book with insights from
the graded team of the series have
confirmed that Kang variants are
sadistically collecting trophies from
the adventures that they've conquered we
began to discuss this not long after
Loki season 1 ended but now as we've
begun to learn a lot more about Kang and
quantumania footage and in Loki season 2
footage a trailer for which that I saw
at d23 and it will hopefully drop online
before the end of the year we can
actually deduce that Kang absolutely
killed Iron Man Tony Stark in another
timeline and in fact based off of what
we know about Kang probably just killed
him in only one timeline and I think it
might explain why there was no Iron Man
in the Illuminati in Universe 838 of
Multiverse of Madness the recently
released book Marvel Studios Loki the
art of the series includes one page
showing concept art of he who remains
steady in the Citadel said decorator
Claudia bonfe gives us a brand new
insight into what exactly we're looking
at here she said that he remains has a
collection of Antiquities the shelves
are full of collections that he's
brought back from throughout the
Universe and they are all related to
either a cultural thing or time or just
anything that's interesting or unique
throughout the Universe I didn't want to
put any bright colors in there it was
all black and gold marble so I stuck
with wood tones that would work maybe
something that had a little bit of a
caramel feel to it a warmth and then was
mixed in with metals and had a nice old
patina feel to it I wanted to draw
attention really to what is happening in
the scene and not the set dressing well
nice try Claudia you did amazing work on
this series I'll give you that but the
psychos here on YouTube are gonna find
Easter eggs no matter how hard you try
to hide and from us we already know that
one of those shelves is an Iron Man
helmet there are a series of other
helmets and pieces of armor there's a
crown with two fangs or horns maybe a
headpiece of a Loki and then over on the
right is a chalkboard that in the series
had Newtonian calculus equations on it
but here in this concept art depicts
geometry and trigonometry reminding us
of Spider-Man no way home when Peter
Parker managed to defeat Doctor Strange
In The Mirror Dimension by trumping
Strange's focus on calculus with a
simpler trick of geometry that calling
back Spider-man homecoming when the
first class of Peter Parker's day was
either trigger physics and Peter knew
the answer to the problem because it
involved the kind of trajectory
equations that Peter has to do in his
head every day when he whips around with
his wedding I mentioned all this because
oh wow bad news Kang also statistically
most likely killed a Spider-Man at some
point too now all these trophies remind
us of uncanny Avengers number eight the
Kang Dynasty 2 000 years in the future
where Kang shows off a trophy room
filled with relics that he snatched from
across the Multiverse including multiple
cap Shields multiple Iron Man helmets a
mjolnir Magneto suit arms Spider-Man
mask Electro Daredevil gear that
literally everything Marvel is in this
room but back in the Citadel over on the
left he remains as a telescope which is
interesting because what exactly is
there to look at from The Citadel other
than the sacred timeline orbiting around
it meaning this Kang variant might
physically look out at moments in
history using this device to inspect
what parts of the timeline must be
adjusted or pruned this telescope is his
eye of Sauron now the latest trailer for
Ant-Man the WASP quantumania shows Scott
Lang meeting Kang the Conqueror who
offers him a deal to give him back time
if he'll steal back something that was
stolen from him Scott says he's an
Avenger and Kang asks you're an Avenger
have I killed you before so akang
definitely killed an Iron Man at some
point in some timeline he who remains as
an Iron Man helmet but that doesn't mean
he remains was the one to kill that Iron
Man he who remains was just the king
variant who used Alliance to defeat all
the other gangs and in that last
multiversal war he remains could have
collected these trophies from other
defeated Kings or even inherited this
whole Citadel from one of the other
kings because remember that broken
statue in the lobby there was a past
struggle in this location now if we
assume several Tony Starks across the
Multiverse had similar life trajectories
at least the way Tony Stark was depicted
in what if there is probably some
pivotal Nexus moment where it would be
the most important for Kang to stop Tony
dead in his tracks Tony certainly came
close to death in many moments in the
kandar province in Afghanistan flying
through that wormhole in 2012 Avengers
fighting Thanos and infinity war on the
guardianship at the beginning of end
game but I've always believed that the
most important moment in Tony Stark's
life as it pertains to Kang nathana
Richards A Thousand Years Later in the
31st century was this moment this time
in the shape of a Mobius strip inverted
please
foreign
yes Tony Stark's discovery of time
travel via Quantum navigation I firmly
believe that this moment and Kang are
connected I love E3000 Nathaniel
Richards birth year being 3 000
something and yeah I also believe that
he remains actually named his prize
Chrono monitor of Mobius and Mobius
after this historic moment Nathaniel
Richards needed Tony Stark to make this
discovery in the year 2023 so that a
thousand years later Nathaniel could
build on Stark's research and master the
technology of time travel and Multiverse
hopping if you think about it that way
that actually makes it pretty precarious
for Kang to ever try to kill Iron Man
because if he needed them that badly to
discover his Missing Link of time travel
for him there would not be many
opportunities after that Discovery for
Kang to kill Tony considering it led
directly to the Time Heist and endgame
in the Battle of Earth in which Tony's
fight with Thanos led to his death
anyway so I think the likeliest universe
in which Kang killed Iron Man was
actually the one Universe we've seen so
far in which Tony was mysteriously
absent Universe 838 of Multiverse
Madness a universe that we know had some
presence of Tony Stark at some some
point in its history with Ultron Sentry
Stark Tech walking around but at the
time we visited it no longer had a Tony
sitting on the Illuminati Deus there was
one open seat but looking back I think
it's likelier that open seat belonged to
either the 838 t'challa or Namor or
maybe Boulder the brave if a3a Tony
Stark was killed by Kang that would
explain why the Illuminati of that
Universe defines multiversal incursions
as side effects of dark hole
dreamwalking and not side effects of any
time travel Mechanics for them
Multiverse awards are caused by dark
magic not 31st Century science a38 seems
to be the one Universe without vertical
time travel though I don't know Charles
Xavier did reference himself and X-Men
Days of Future Past so who knows it
might have consciousness-based time
travel as a rule to it have I thought
more about this than the filmmakers have
at this point yeah definitely that's why
you should hire me Marvel but really how
ironic is it that whether by future
scientists using technology or by
Wizards and witches using an evil spell
book in dark magic the Multiverse is
destined one way or another to collapse
into chaos it's almost like neither of
these things are really causing it it's
just gonna collapse on itself anyway and
incursions are the fate of all of us but
I want to ask you do you think we'll
ever see a killing Montage in which Kang
Slaughters Avengers I mean I don't know
marvel did get cold feet and removed
Gore doing the same thing to the Gods in
Thor love and thunder My Hope Is that
they actually cut that so that it would
have more impact when Kang does it to
Avengers in Kang Dynasty let me know
your thoughts down below follow me on
Tick Tock Instagram and Twitter at hey
boss follow new rockstars And subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you